if there was a day and I'm old enough to  remember before anything got x-rayed you  know why because nobody had an x-ray  machine to do it and in the 1960s there  was a Spate of of hijackings many of  them were to Cuba so Congress said we  got to stop this the only way we can do  it is maybe we can x-ray your luggage oh  yeah astrophysicists of the early 1970s  had just miniaturized x-ray detectors to  put into satellites to observe the  universe in the X-ray part of the  spectrum the X-ray machines are huge and  so a company called American Science and  Engineering based in Cambridge  Massachusetts  pioneered small x-ray detectors and then  they got tapped by the government and  say will you bring those into every  airport in the country and thus was born  x-ray detectors at airports because of  astrophysicists